mesdames et messieurs bonsoir cet après
midi à paris la dépouille de jean paul
sartre a été conduite de l'hôpital
broussais où il est décédé au cimetière
montparnasse en empruntant les grandes
avenues du 14e arrondissement
il y avait énormément de monde est en
fait la foule n'a cessé de grossir
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans cette foule un fort
pourcentage de jeunes ce qui est un
témoignage de l'impact de l'oeuvre du
grand écrivain sauvageau
un commentaire d'alain gillot-pétré qui
a suivi le cortège tourner
14h15 le cortège funèbre de jean paul
sartre quitte l'hôpital broussais dans
la foule
michel rocard yves montand et simone
signoret françois perrier quelques
policiers avec fourragères et gants
blancs assure un service d'honneur sur
le premier fourgon d'immenses gerbes de
fleurs de libération gallimard les temps
modernes un bateau pour le vietnam et
l'amicale des algériens en europe
simone de beauvoir et les intimes de
jean paul sartre ont pris place près du
cercueil
la dernière marche de ça la marche pour
sartre commence solitaire cet homme là
allons donc tantôt un fleuve à traverser
paris de part en part à padum le pas de
milliers d'hommes pour un homme qui
l'ont aimée pour un homme qui l'ont
suivi qu'ils suivent ici pour la
dernière fois
concernant un écrivain il faut remonter
aux obsèques de victor hugo en 1885 pour
avoir une idée de ce qui s'est passé à
paris cet après midi sans aucun service
d'ordre
la foule silencieuse et recueillie s'est
emparé de la rue créant de monstrueux
embouteillages paris était à ça plus le
cortège progressait dans le 14e
arrondissement plus le monde affluaient
les trottoirs se remplissait le défilé
digérant au passage la masse compacte de
nouveaux arrivants et ceux qui avaient
donné rendez-vous à sartre au long de
son dernier voyage
dix mille à broussais 50000 l arrivée au
moins une majorité de jeunes mais toutes
les générations sartrienne est elle à
l'arrivée d'une telle marée devait
provoquer au cimetière d'inévitables
bousculade on dénombra plusieurs blessés
et tout fait dans la houle humaine mais
la spontanéité de l'hommage rendu à sa
sa simplicité
cette curieuse atmosphère de liberté
efface toute autre considération
c'est à grand peine que le cercueil
marron très simple de jean paul sartre
pu être extrait de fourgons mortuaires
à
simone de beauvoir
la dépouille de jean paul sartre sera
incinéré mercredi pour père lachaise
une explosion s'est produite aujourd'hui
vers 18h45 après midi dans un foyer
d'étudiants protestant rue de vaugirard
26e quatre blessés dont un est dans un
état grave
l'explosion dans la nature n'est pas
encore déterminé pourrait être d'origine
criminelle
vous donneront d'autres détails notre
dernière édition 6 il rend le président
carter a reçu plusieurs rapports de ce
que l'ayatollah khomeini n'avait pas
l'intention de libérer les otages de
l'ambassade avant la fin des élections
présidentielles aux états unis or celles
ci ont lieu en novembre et cela signifie
que les otages seraient restés
emprisonnés pente un cadre représentant
les familles des otages deux épouse et
de mère se rendent lundi en europe dans
le but de faire connaître leurs
inquiétudes aux européens avant le
sommet des nefs qui se réunit fin avril
à luxembourg
ces quatre dames font partie d'un groupe
qui a pris le nom de flag initiale des
mots anglais signifiant groupe d'action
et de liaison des familles elles veulent
se faire entendre non pas seulement des
chefs d'état mais sow bintel des simples
familles comme les nôtres et ce matin
arrivée à terrain d'un couple que vous
connaissez bien et que vous avez vu au
début de la semaine ici même au journal
de 20 heures monsieur madame team
la mère et le beau-père de la tâche de
plus jeunes de l'ambassade des
etats-unis à téhéran
le sergent r morgue les formalités
douanières ont été très brève
monsieur et madame team en ont tiré
l'espoir de parvenir à rencontrer leur
fils sans trop attendre souhaitons que
leur voeu soit exaucé en avant dans la
situation s'est brusquement tendue cet
après midi à téhéran où des airs très
violents ont opposé des étudiants à des
membres d'un parti extrémiste religieux
il y a eu un mort et 50 blessés parmi
les étudiants
le conseil de la révolution a décidé la
fermeture de toutes les universités dans
la capitale iranienne
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a réagi
la nuit dernière avec une indignation
unanime à l'assassinât de deux casques
bleus irlandais par les milices
conservatrice libanaise le quai d'orsay
a exprimé aujourd'hui son indignation et
sa grave préoccupation à la suite des
événements qui ont amené la mort de ces
deux irlandais qui faisait partie des
casques bleus
la finul c'est à dire la force
internationale de l'onu pour le libre
l'homme qui est à l'origine de ces deux
assassinats
c'est lui le commandant saad haddad chef
des milices chrétiennes du sud liban il
ya une semaine ces hommes avaient
vainement tenté de prendre sous leur
contrôle
un village tenu par le contingent
irlandais de l'onu au cours de l'
attaque de miliciens étaient morts
provoquant la fureur du commandant
haddad qui avait exigé qu'au l'onu lui
livrent deux soldats et 50 mille francs
français à titre de compensation
la suite on la devine les milices
chrétiennes ont enlevé deux casques
bleus hier soir et les ont froidement
exécutés d'une balle dans la nuque après
le raid israélien d'hier dans la région
de saïda
ces deux assassinats au fait nettement
monter la tension dans cette région du
monde dont on ne parlait plus le
problème c'est que les forces des
nations unies sont littéralement prises
entre deux feux entre les palestiniens
au nord et les milices chrétiennes au
sud
résultat depuis le début de leur mandat
au sud liban les casques bleus ont perdu
43 hommes mais c'est la première fois
que des soldats sans armes sont abattus
de sang-froid
reste que la multiplication d'incidents
ces gens fait craindre à beaucoup de
libanais un nouvel embrasement de la
région une crainte qui est d'autant plus
fondée qu'en juin prochain le mandat des
casques bleus arrivent à expiration ce
qui créera forcément un vide dangereux
au sud liban
le pape a l'intention de rendre visite
l'an prochain au conseil de l'europe à
strasbourg
c'est ce qu'annonce son seigneur et le
charger archevêque de cette ville le
parlement européen serait associé à la
visite
en fait jean paul ii ne viendrait pas
seulement pour les institutions
européennes mais aussi pour strasbourg
et pour l'alsace grèce le premier
ministre monsieur karam m10 et annoncé
qu'il était candidat à la présidence de
la république
je vous rappelle que monsieur caramanlis
qui avait quitté son pays pendant
l'époque du régime fasciste des colonels
avait passé tout son exil à passe au
brésil nombreuses arrestations parmi les
syndicalistes de la métallurgie à sao
paulo notamment celle du trésorier du
syndicat de la métallurgie et de l'ex
président de la commission justice et
paix du diocèse de sao paulo et la fp
rapporte que selon un député de
l'opposition
cette vague d'arrestations est d'une
ampleur sans précédent le journal
moscovite komsomolskaïa pravda a mis au
point une campagne de cartes postales
que les lecteurs trouvent toutes
imprimées en anglais dans leur journal
est destiné à être envoyée au président
carter le texte à peu près votre
politique pousse notre planète vers la
bim cubain après une interruption de
quelques heures les départs des cubains
candidats à la fuite ont repris 230
personnes après avoir fait escale au
costa rica son arrivée à lima pérou
pendant ce temps les autorités castriste
ont organisé un meeting monstre contre
ceux qui veulent partir de la havane
notre envoyé spécial bernard ont fait la
preuve que le gouvernement se tenir au
monde après quelques jours c'est
désarroi des choses rentrent dans l'eau
les phases un hasard si la presse du
monde entier et c'est à ce titre il est
parfaitement réglé samedi en france
qu'on ferait depuis dix ans du matin
pour fonder mars militaires et de ce qu
il ya de la dialyse du principe
défenseur attend les idées de tout poil
les idées reçues en direct par la ceni
cossu belle en dehors de la face au mas
du passo cortese la havane efficacement
désert le seul ici représenté réfugiés
n'est toujours pas réglée par cette
manifestation originale aujourd'hui dans
paris de l'opéra la concorde où l'on a
pu assister à un concert de piano
ambulant organisé par l'aïd à
l'association internationale de défense
des artistes but protester contre
l'emprisonnement de la pianiste ruben al
baba sall et souza un peu longue
cet artiste de 46 ans fut exilé une
première fois du reggae en argentine
mais après l'enlèvement de son fils
s'appelle dont on reste sans nouvelles
depuis quatre ans elle est allée en
colombie sous une fausse identité là en
colombie donc elle a déjà passé une
année de détention préventive durant
laquelle selon ses proches elle aurait
subi des tortures actuellement albert
gonzalez souza est jugée à bogota pas un
prime une ammonite est monsieur le
theule ministre des transports a lancé
aujourd'hui à rtl à propos de la marée
noire que les travaux de colmatage de la
brèche du tanio allait commencer et puis
de nouvelles dispositions
internationales sont en préparation avec
le concours des britanniques et des
allemands pour que la manche ville
ministre ne soit plus le lieu du risque
1980 at il continué restera une année
expérimentale pour les codes en ville
les consultations se poursuivent avec le
concours de l'académie de médecine
selon monsieur le theule les codes sont
acceptées par 80 % des automobilistes en
province et sont surtout contesté à
paris si vous prenez le métro vous
paierez les tickets de seconde au moins
un franc 75 à partir de juillet ce sera
le prix en achetant vos billets par
carnet de 10 actuellement sabots un
franc cinquante prix en termes et 10
augmentation donc de 16%
le bimensuel économique l'expansion
vient de réaliser un sondage intéressant
parmi ses lecteurs des cadres un grande
majorité ils ont été plusieurs milliers
à répondre à l' enquête de leur journal
pour indiquer dans quelle direction
devrait s'orienter leurs loisirs mais
aussi pour faire le point de l'usaj que
ces cadres font des loisirs que leur
laisse leur travail
premier fait étonnant 21 % des cadres ne
prennent pas toutes les vacances
auxquelles ils ont droit par surcroît de
travail pour la plupart par absence de
besoin pour les autres mais aussi par
manque de moyens ils sont quand même 74
% à souhaiter plus de loisirs ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils veulent de plus
en plus de petites vacances et des
week-ends prolongés pour casser le
rythme de leurs annette
vas y ce choix s'opère au détriment des
vacances d'été 54% des cadres ne partent
pas plus de trois semaines étaient les
cadres et leurs familles sont plutôt
sportif 11% seulement déclare qu'il ne
pratique aucun sport pour les autres ce
sont la natation 31% le ski et le vélo
28% et le tennis qui remportent leurs
suffrages
pour les week-ends à l'extérieur
seulement 8 % des cadres quittent leur
résidence principale chaque semaine 31%
par une ou deux fois par mois la
majorité 42% ne se déplace que pour les
lots week end les loisirs se sont aussi
les soirées en priorité les cadres
lisent des journaux des revues puis
regarde la télévision lisent un livre ou
écoutent de la musique
le temps passé avec les enfants ne vient
qu'en sixième position et les spectacles
au huitième rang de leurs occupations
monsieur olivier richard ancien ministre
d'état et maire de la baule s'inquiète
du climat politique qui s'est développé
autour de la sphère de breuil ils
dénoncent ce qu'ils appellent les
vendettas électoraliste et monsieur
richard lance un appel à l'unité et à la
dignité
puis je comprend bien l'intérêt qu'ont
les communistes le socialiste pour les
procès politiques je trouve inadmissible
qu'un tel majorité quelqu'un se prête
cette espèce de portemine qu'elle
devrait être pour vous l'attitude
égoïste d'avoir la digue était vis-à-vis
de ce genre de problème que le général
laurent sais c'est que nous y réellement
ce qu'est ce n'est pas quand même un peu
le contrecoup de la bataille pour les
élections présidentielles jeunes et demi
dans que la préparation de l'élection
présidentielle m'arrangerait
je pense que en matière d'élection
présidentielle
d'ailleurs le plus grand intérêt genou
français avait le plus grand intérêt à
voir la campagne se déroule et seulement
à partir du moment où le candidat se
serait déclaré parce qu'avant c'est
vraiment pas très brillant
apparemment il semble qu'il puisse y
avoir deux candidats se réclamant du
gaullisme
ce sont les apparences nous attendre et
pour le prononcé de les connaître
souhaiteriez-vous une candidature unique
de la majorité présidentielle j'ai
toujours été favorable
législatives et aux présidentielles mais
on dirait qu'en 69 c'est en effet ce qui
s'est passé c'est dur a été favorable
aux candidatures uniques parce que je
crois qu'elle colle mieux à l'esprit de
nos institutions qui suppose une
majorité relativement bien soudée les
enfants devront connu des prix mais ne
sommes pas morts pour le premier
trimestre 80 le déficit commercial de la
france a atteint plus de 14 milliards de
francs soit moitié plus en trois mois
que durant la totalité de l'année
dernière
prenant connaissance de ces chiffres
dans sa circonscription de neige
monsieur bart a déclaré tous les pays
industriels connaissent le même problème
pour nous ce qui compte c'est de
maintenir la stabilité de notre monnaie
nous pouvons le faire car ne disposant
de réserves importantes puisque nos
exportations continuent à croître alors
sur le même sujet commentaires de
monsieur laurent fabius
le porte-parole du ps monsieur giscard
d'estaing dit il est le champion de
france des promesses non tenues le
gouvernement qui refuse toute
planification et toutes réformes
économiques de fonds devraient avoir
l'honnêteté de reconnaître que sa
politique n'est par apple
toujours au parti socialiste michel
rocard mis en cause par la direction du
ps pour la discipline a décidé de
différer tous les déplacements tous les
déplacements qui avait prévu
d'entreprendre dans les fédérations
à partir de ce mardi qui vient 22 avril
il répond ainsi aux reproches qui lui
sont adressés
le député des yvelines invoque son souci
de préserver l'unité du parti
mais il souhaite aussi que la direction
du ps prenne la responsabilité de lui
interdire d'être candidat
changeons d'horizon si le printemps est
à peu près installé chez nous en
revanche dans le grand nord en laponie
norvégienne par exemple il fait toujours
terriblement froid gérard val
mazeyrolles en tourte viennent de vivre
quelques jours dans une des petites
villes du grand nord lapon c'est une des
agglomérations les plus septentrionales
de la planète
ultima thulé l'extrême-nord
c'est ainsi que tacite l'écrivain latin
appelait ses immensités glacées
maintenant surnommé le toit de l'europe
en fait c'est la laponie norvégienne
dans la région administrative du
finnmark
hélas à 800 km au dessus du cercle
polaire près du cap nord lille de vars 2
à un fjord de l'urss vieille cité
baleinière var deux vit toujours des
bateaux est maintenant de la pêche
industrielle surtout en mer de barents
très généreuse et qu'ils ne gèlent
jamais grâce à une clé de gulfstream
4000 habitants serein pour la plupart
d'origine chinoise et une fierté locale
l'école internationale de pêche attirant
des élèves du monde entier
cette île du grand nord est séparée du
continent par 3 km de mer un ferry boat
fait donc l'aller-retour toutes les
heures même quand le blizzard soufflé si
fort que les lapons retrouve
naturellement leur marche pencher sur
l'avant depuis la destruction de la
ville pendant leur repli allemands alors
que les soviétiques et des la résistance
norvégienne oslo promettait un grand
pont île continent
car bien qu apparemment isolés var 2 est
pourtant très actif
alors pour se faire pardonner cette trop
longue attente le gouvernement finance
actuellement une autre solution bien
plus audacieux
la solution un tunnel tube 2600 mètres
dans la roche du sous-sol de la mer à 90
mètres sous la surface
300 millions de francs livraison fin 80
utilisation gratuite
septe 2000 une c'est le front de taille
actuellement au tiers du parcours
cet homme seulement sur le chantier au
fond du trou et un seul pour manoeuvrer
la machine française sorte d'énorme
crabes dont les pins seraient devenus
des gigantesques roulette du dentiste
ce sera donc aussi la fin du tunnel pour
var 2 qui s'impatientent de son
désenclavement
après avoir longtemps tiré parti de sa
position insulaire témoin en est cette
forteresse type vauban dont les canons
ne servent plus qu'à saluer chaque année
le retour du soleil
le 21 janvier après deux mois de nuit
polaire de loin tout paraît figée par le
froid
mais les norvégiens savent glisser avant
de marcher et la vie continue
exemple un dimanche matin dans le
dépouillement père du temple luthérien
le pasteur s'apprête à baptiser elin
trois mois
lui
extrait pour d'une femme au pont de
presse sylvie tenez ce pire des
menteuses torture ou pour d'un crochet
festin des sources christophe au repas
des murs du cap nord
jonnhy au soleil domine des lapons
parlant de leurs ancêtres raconte que
ses fruits et les norvégiennes ont
beaucoup adouci l'exil d'un futur roi de
france un certain louis philippe jeu par
une valeur d'un certain nombre de
mesures annoncées par monsieur le theule
en voici une autre réduction de 40% du
péage consenti bientôt aux motocyclistes
sur l'autoroute paris lyon marseille et
il est possible de cette diminution soit
étendu à l'ensemble du réseau français
d'autre part les fanatiques de la moto
qui était aujourd'hui au mans pour les
24 heures cyclistes et bien c'est une
nouvelle qui leur est fait très plaisir
quant à l'épreuve elle-même la voici
présenté par hervé duthu
pas de surprise actuellement dans cette
troisième édition des 24 heures du mans
moto après un peu plus de cinq heures de
course marc fontan et hervé moineau sur
honda meilleur temps aux essais sont en
tête et ce depuis le départ
pour marc fontan dernière recrue de
l'écurie d'endurance honda c'est en
quelque sorte la confirmation après sa
cinquième place au 200 milles de daytona
et sa victoire autre fait du million
derrière eux on trouve les grands
favoris de l'épreuve christian lyon et
jean claude chaumard un vainqueur ici
même l'année dernière ces deux hommes
talonnait d'ailleurs leurs coéquipiers
lorsque tous avant 18 heures puis sur
les ondes vertes et qu'un arrêt de six
minutes à son stand sur rupture de recul
de ses lecteurs rétrogradé à la 5e place
après cet incident christian léon et
jean-claude czmara revenait pourtant
rapidement la deuxième place mais à
trois tours de fontan moineaux derrière
les deux honda on trouve à l'heure
actuelle une japauto et une suzuki alors
que 11 des 51 concurrents alignés au
départ ont déjà abandonné
cela dit la course risque de connaître
de multiples rebondissements car la
météo annonce de la pluie pour la nuit
ouais
chercher demain à longchamp dans leur
handicap prix que notre corps peut pas
me porte
il y aura beaucoup de partants 23 il
devait mettre 24 mercun souffrent d'un
accès de fièvre et il restera à l'écurie
pour le soigner cet accès la
numérotation des chaînes étrangères
pierrette brès qui comme plusieurs
concurrents de la course et vécu sa
rentrée vous d'amman à vis de ce tir oui
ces tirs s'est doté de 5000 francs de
trio gagnant se disputera sur une courte
distance 1950 m mais cette distance
paraîtra bien longue
parce que l'arrivée s'effectue au
deuxième poteau et la ligne droite à
longchamp semble vraiment interminable
pour les chevaux c'est une épreuve
handicap ouverte aux chevaux âgés de 4 à
5 ans que nous avons l'habitude de
retrouver dans tous les tirs c'est
similaire mais avant de vous donner un
pronostic je voudrais vous présenter les
deux favoris que j'ai choisi deux
favoris qui ne feront qu'un pendant la
course d'orbec monté par un jeune
apprenti serge bories
regardez les ils forment un couple
parfait la force la puissance du cheval
dominé par l'équilibré le talent du
petit jockey est ce que dans ma tête un
choix facile
hier j'ai fort d'être la ducasse et
dimanche avec d'orbec vous savez il faut
que hyundai
il faut bien il faut qu'elle faisait
confiance à endormait penser qu'il peut
le faire
pourquoi j'aime bien qu'il va vite il va
vite très dense et plus cher son jeu
fait que vous admirez le plus c'est
martin je sais que j'ai essayé de
l'imiter point c'est tout c'est pas
toujours facile
pourquoi seulement été difficile mais
c'est le meilleur produit tout sur lui
j'avais déjà battu les grands jockeys
lequel dit
mais alors quel effet ça c'est de battre
la diagonale est comme ça qu'est ce que
c'est mais le cheval pourquoi ces
moucherons et c'est vous apporte ses pas
j'aime mes chaussons vous avez quel âge
il ne sais pas je ne sais pas combien de
mesurer pas grand chose c'est qu'il faut
le moins que du caractère de 2,2 d'orbec
d'abord ces légendes ont franchi ses
nerfs de l'impasse et surtout un bon
alors on vous laisse partir parce que
oui et d'orbec était déjà favori dans un
tiercé le 7 avril elle n'a pas pu
prendre part à la course parce qu'au
dernier moment son petit jo tu es tombé
malade il n'a pas pu être remplacé mais
finalement ça l' avantage parce que là
il porte encore 46 kilos et demi et ses
chances sont intactes
alors j'en fais mon grand favori alors
mon deuxième sera les aspres qui était à
cheval plutôt malchanceux et finit
toujours 2e mais enfin c'est une valeur
sûre dans un tiercé les toujours
l'arrivée n'arrive pas à gagner tant pis
quand google est un jeu spécialisé
handicap à longchamp on peut compter sur
lui des serveurs viennent de participer
à l'arrivée d'un tiercé deuxièmes et
troisièmes ils ont encore des chances
cette fois-ci ensuite de talent il est
souvent décevant mais dans un bon jour
bon jour il peut surprendre
et puis derrière lui manque qui est un
cheval de classe mais avec 61 kg sa
tâche n'est pas facile alors je mets
tout en bas de mon choix et je
terminerai par chérubin qui lui aussi
aura du fil à retordre et par 59 kg la
tâche sera dur aussi pour lui alors ses
cheveux porteront les numéros 26,4 15 11
un idée voilà il n'y aura pas que tiercé
il y aura deux écoles classiques comme
on dit alors je vais vous demander de
faire un pronostic peut-être aller au
travers d'un cycle mais je vous dis
reprendre dans vos vacances quels sont
les chevaux je veux bien courir et qui
paraîtront dans le prix noailles et dans
le prix de guiche dragons qui a gagné le
grand critérium d'année dernière et qui
sans doute très très bon et puis 1re
êtres qui la dernière fois a terminé à
100 à l'heure et aucun à distance de
mâcon vient battre comme ça vous savez
la puissance américaine est elle en
train de décliner ce qui dirige la
politique américaine
sont-ils à la hauteur de leur tâche aux
dates deux questions parmi cinquante
autres qui seront posées ici même en
direct à l'ex-président des états-unis
monsieur richard nixon
qui sera l'invitée d'antenne de midi
après demain lundi à l'occasion de la
sortie à paris chez albin michel de son
livre la vraie guerre où il est je parle
de ceux nixon oui il est très dur pour
l'administration carter et il a
peut-être à proposer des solutions de
remplacement n'en sais rien de toute
manière son interview mérite d'être
suivie avec beaucoup d'attention
notre confrère france soir publie à
partir d'aujourd'hui un supplément
france soir week end il s'agit de huit
pages que vous trouvez dans toutes ses
éditions vie quotidienne sport spectacle
est aujourd'hui un reportage sur le
marché révolte en dvd avant même si la
température vient de franchir en france
nous avons senti nous avons vécu tous
ces jours ci la très belle première
semaine de l'année et toutes ces
musiques que nous avons des rires la
tête ont commencé à se dégeler à danser
avec le soleil et les feuilles quelque
chose en nous s'est mis à fredonner
celles prêtes musique en tête en tout
cas et un blanc et rose nous précise
louis hawks valerio long la poussière de
savoie le citron un refrain populaire
sans rime ni raison aucune
et voici son fait vint pas jean paul
amar a sans doute ne les connaissez vous
pas ou pas encore mes nerfs sur notre
antenne vous est familier sans titre
amour et printemps une musique sur
laquelle tout parole aujourd'hui serait
superflu
m
ne tourne
où
et
non
m
tous
on
e
alors prévisions météo pour demain
dimanche de la manche et des frontières
du nord-est au nord du massif central et
des alpes temps variable passagèrement
nuageux avec des averses sur le reste de
la france temps nuageux mais avec des
éclaircies assez belle dans l'ouest et
sur les côtes du golfe du lion cependant
des nuages d'abondants resteront
accrochées au versant lors des pires et
quelques ondées encore l' agence pour
les économies d'énergie recommande de
maintenir à la rave au chauffage en
plein dans les régions comme l'aquitaine
midi pyrénées languedoc roussillon
provence côte d'azur et corse ailleurs
vous pourrez remettre le chauffage
mais attention à ne jamais dépasser 19
degrés est pour les renseignements
concernant la conduite de votre
chauffage vous pouvez appeler à paris le
5 166 07 66 c'est à dire que si vous
appelez de province ouverte le 16 le 1
566 07 66 ce soir vers 23 heures c'est
gérard holtz qui vous donnera les
dernières informations
et si tel est votre bon plaisir nous
offrons demain comme vingtaine de miti
bon soir